Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo zusammen und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von
Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Stefan Netzeband
hallo in unserer heutigen Folge widmen
wir uns Kunst und Krempel und der dem
rechtmäßigen Eigentümer eines Gemäldes
die einem Krimi gleicht Gast in unserer
heutigen Folge ist mal wieder Walter
Straten der ist stellvertretender
sportchefredakteur von Bild und
absoluter Kunstexperte und Fan der
Sendung Kunst und Krempel im Bayerischen
Rundfunk und dort beginnt auch unser
heutiger
Fall
ich wurde aufmerksam auf den Fall im
November 2008 ich sah eine meiner
Lieblingssendung Kunst und Krempel im
Bayerischen Rundfunk im dritten Programm
TV Programm wo Besitzer ja von Kunst
oder Krempel Experten ihre Sachen zeigen
und da tauchte ein Mann auf mit einem
sehr querformatigen Gemälde leicht zu
identifizieren auch signiert Franz
Franken es zeigt Jesus auf dem Berg der
J Fall mehr ein Hügel ist vor einer
andächtig Zuhörenden Menge eine Frau
stellt gerade ihr Kind sehr viele
Details drin im Hintergrund ist die
Stadt die woh Jerusalem darstellt und
Jesus Predigt von der Liebe vom Frieden
von Gewaltlosigkeit das ist ja
vielleicht die eindrucksvollste
Friedensbotschaft der
Menschheitsgeschichte und deswegen ist
es auch eine gewisse Ironie dass dieses
Gemälde zur Beute der möglicherweise
oder wahrschein die schlimmsten
Kriegsverbrecher der
Menschheitsgeschichte wurde denn zu dem
Zeitpunkt als Walter das Gemälde mit dem
Titel Bergpredigt von Franz Franken bei
Kunst und Krempel sieht gilt das Gemälde
eigentlich seit mehr als 60 Jahren als
vermisst aber der Reihe
nach der Kandidat und die Experten
wissen das natürlich während der Sendung
nicht der Mann erzählt die Bergpredigt
wurde in seiner Familie über mehrere
Generationen vererbt wie es genau vorher
seiner Familie landete das sei jedoch
ungewiss nicht nur der stellvertretende
bildsport Chefredakteur sieht an diesem
Novembertag im Jahr 2008 die
Kultursendung auch der Münchner
Kunsthistoriker Stefan klingen schaut zu
und wird Stutz sich dieses Bild das
kommt ihm doch irgendwie bekannt
vor monatelang lässt die Bergpredigt
klingen keine Ruhe bis er im September
2009 in einem
die abgebildete Bergpredigt entdeckt und
Heka wenn ich das mal so sagen darf oder
Halleluja Frank frrankens Gemälde wurde
1945 mit mehr als 600 weiteren
Kunstwerken aus dem führerbau in München
gestohlen und nie wiedergefunden bis
jetzt umgehend alarmiert Kunsthistoriker
klingen das bayerische LKA die
Bergpredigt wird beschlagnahmt Verdacht
auf fehlerei und landet Schluss bei der
Münchner
Staatsanwaltschaft bitte LKA
Staatsanwaltschaft ziemlich große
Aufregung für ein gar nicht mal so
großes Gemälde damit wir besser
verstehen wieso reisen wir jetzt einmal
gemeinsam in die 1940er Jahre der Zweite
Weltkrieg ist im Gange Hitler beginnt
viele Länder Europas unter seine
Kontrolle zu bringen Größen warahnsinnig
plante er unter anderem sein
führermuseum im österreichischen Linz
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sollen hier
imposante Kunstwerke ausgestellt werden
unter dem Sonderauftrag Linz so der
Deckname Reisen Kunstkenner darunter
auch Hildebrand gurlit durch Europa um
Kunstwerke für das geplante Museum zu
kaufen die meisten davon kommen jedoch
nicht rechtmäßig in den Besitz der Nazis
sondern werden ihren Besitzern wenn man
es ehrlich formuliert einfach geraubt ja
Frankreich war nach der deutschen
Besatzung der Hotspot der Umschlagplatz
für geraubte Kunst man muss wissen dass
die beiden mächtigsten Männer des
Nationalsozialismus beide Kunstsammler
waren teilweise auch fanatische Hermann
Göring und adamf Hitler in Konkurrenz
stehend oft genug Hitler sammelte für
sein führermuseum in erster Linie Göring
für seinen Landsitz Karin Hall das Ziel
war die prächtigsten Kunstwerke
zusammenzaffen die man in Frankreich und
auch in den Niederlanden und Belgien
zusammen en konnte es gab einen
Umschlagplatz in Paris das sogenannte
jede POM ist ein Museum das ist liegt
direkt neem Louve dort lief ein Großteil
der geraubten vielleicht auch so halb
semilegal gekauften Kunstwerke Z zu
Spotpreisen dort wurden sie
katalogisiert zusammengefasst die
kunstrafgier von beiden hat natürlich es
befeuert dass sehr viele Sammler private
Sammler natürlich in jetzt jüdische
Sammler ausgeraubt wurden erpresst
wurden dass sie sozusagen möglicherweise
ihre Kunstwerke gegen ihr Leben
tauschten manchmal auch beides verloren
haben die Kunstwerke die sich Hitler für
sein geplantes Museum in Linz aussucht
werden im Keller des führerbaus in der
Münchner arzisstraße gelagert bis zur
Nacht vom 29 auf den 30 April
1945 das Ende des Krieges Naht mit einer
Niederlage Deutschlands bekannterweise
amerikanische Truppen haben bereits das
KZ in Dachau befreit und befinden sich
auf dem Vormarsch nach München wenige
Stunden später wird sich Hitler das
Leben nehmen man kann es sich vorstellen
in München macht sich eine gewisse
Endzeitstimmung breit die Straßen der
bayischen Landeshauptstadt sind wie leer
gefegt schwer groß und einsam prankt der
führerbau in der arzisstraße die Wachen
die bis vor wenigen Stunden noch das
nazebäude schützten sind inzwischen
geflohen der Keller des Gebäudes ist
voll wie wir wissen mit wertvollen
Gemälden und Kunstwerken aber nicht nur
das Hitler bunkert dort unter anderem
auch Wein und Bier in einem eigenen
Kühlraum wird zudem noch Wild und
Geflügel
gelagert die Nachricht vom gefüllten
Keller und den geflohenen Wachen scheint
in München die Runde zu machen
unbekannte machen sich in den
Abendstunden auf zum führerbau und
plündern die Kellerräume in wenigen
Stunden sind die Regale und Kühlräume
leer geräumt die Zellen in denen mehr
als 600 Meisterwerke Lager auch wer die
Einbrecher waren wo die Gemälde hin sind
das ist bis heute unklar immerhin 130
Gemälde können die Ermittler danach
wiederfinden und an die rechtmäßigen
Eigentümer übergeben der Großteil bleibt
aber verschollen der Einbruch in den
führerbau gilt bis heute als eine der
größten kunstraube des 20
Jahrhunderts zurück ins Jahr 2009 die
Ermittlungen beginnen um festzustellen
wer der rechtmäßige Eigentümer der
Bergpredigt ist wie sich herausstellt
war der Großonkel des Kandidaten bei
Kunst und Krempel Alois R einst NS
kasernenwart war Alois R einer der
Einbrecher im führerbau wie kam er an
die Bergpredigt die Fragen versucht
Walter Straten zu beantworten da ist man
weiß es ja nicht ganz genau muss man
auch dazu sagen dieser
kasernenwart dessen Familie das Bild den
bernommen hat ist möglicherweise in
einen dieser Kellerräume des führerbars
eingedrungen man weiß auch genau in
welcher Zelle dieses Bild lag das haben
die Nazis auch schön fein säuberlich
dokumentiert und hat's mitgenommen
andere Theorie er hat es denn kurze Zeit
später in den Wirren entweder des
Krieges oder der direkten Nachkriegszeit
auf dem Schwarzmarkt gekauft man weiß es
eben nicht genau er ist natürlich längst
tot dessen Tochter der das Bild
geschenkt hat inzwischen ich glaube im
Jahr 2012 auch verstorben und nun sind
also die Erben da die jetzt auch die
genauen Umstände nicht wissen da kann
man noch nur spekulieren Kunsthistoriker
klingen findet jedenfalls die Antwort
auf die Frage wie die Bergpredigt in den
führerbau kam und zwar in den Unterlagen
von Hildebrand gurlit hier sei mal ein
kleiner Einschub erlaubt falls euch der
Name bekannt vorkommt gurlit hieß auch
Cornelius gurlit bei dem Jahrzehnte
später noch viel viel mehr raubkun st
gefunden wurde aber zurück Hitlers
Kunstexperte gurlit also der Vater der
Vorfahr kaufte 1943 im damals besetzten
Frankreich die Bergpredigt für 7500
Reichsmark und verkaufte diese im
Anschluss an den Planungsstab des Linzer
Museums so landet das Gemälde im Keller
aber wem gehörte die Bergpredigt bevor
sie git in Frankreich kaufte das ist
unklar eine Spur führt nach Wien während
der Besatzung der Nazis wird die
Kunstsammlung der Jüden Valerie Honig
taxiert und beschlagnahmt darunter ein
gemälldde mit dem Titel Bergpredigt der
notierte Künstler Franz Franken Valerie
Honig wurde deportiert und ermordet
gehörte also das Bild das gurlet Jahre
später in Frankreich kaufte tatsächlich
Valerie Honig Kunsthistoriker klingen
hält es gegenüber der FAZ für höchst
unwahrscheinlich dass ein Bild aus
Österreich auf dem französischen
Kunstmarkt verkauft wurde auch Erben von
Valerie Honig oder jüdische
Interessenvertretung machen nach
Auffinden der Bergpredigt jedenfalls
keinen Anspruch geltend auf dieses Bild
und jetzt liebe Zuhörer wird es etwas
knefflig ja sogar juristisch hier bei
Talort Deutschland fassen wir noch mal
zusammen
1945 stielt jemand die Bergpredigt aus
dem führerbau ob Alois R Großonkel des
Kandidaten bei Kunst und Krempel einer
der Diebe war oder das mälde auf dem
Schwarzmarkt gekauft oder getauscht hat
ist unklar fest steht zuvor kaufte
goldit Franz Frankens Gemälde in
Frankreich ob es davor der jüdenwalerie
Honig gehörte kann nicht
einhundertprozentig bestätigt
werden ziemlich vertragte
Besitzverhältnisse die Justiz zieht 2014
also 5 Jahre nachdem Ermittler die
Bergpredigt beschlagnammt haben auf
jeden Fall ein Schlussstrich ein
Amtsgericht urteilt ursprüngliche
Eigentümerin der Bergpredigt war die
Jüden Valerie Honig spricht das Gemälde
aber den Erben von NS kasernenwart Alois
R zu der Diebstahl nämlich der sei
verjährt die Erben hätten sich das
übernommene gut in gutem Glauben
ersessen ersessen ist ein schöner
Begriff man behält es so lange bis es
einem gehört das Gericht folgt damit der
Auffassung des Bundesamtes für offene
Vermögensfragen hätte das Amtsgericht
Valerie Honig nicht als Eigentümerin
festgestellt hätte das Gemälde der
Bundesrepublik als Eigentümerin
zugesprochen werden müssen denn diese
folgt als rechtliche Nachfolgerin des
Deutschen Reichs heißt im Klartext das
Bundesamt hätte einen raubkunstskandal
am Hals hätte hätte hätte tja hätte man
kann sich natürlich vorstellen diese
Entscheidung sorgt damals für einige
Empörung und kein Wunder dass die Erben
von Alois R das Bild natürlich schnell
loswerden möchten das Münchner
Auktionshaus Neumeister übernimmt das
gem de versucht auf eigene Faust auch
noch einmal die Herkunft zu erforschen
vergeblich auch hier wieder das
Auktionshaus bietet das Gemälde
schließlich auch noch öffentlichen
Museen an aber auch das vergeblich kein
Museum möchte dieses Bild
Ende September dieses Jahres also
2023 kommt es dann schlussendlich zur
Versteigerung knapp 15 Jahre nachdem man
nichts an in der Erbe zu Kunst und
Krempel ging und mit seinem Auftritt
einen kunstkremi Rollen brachte eines
unserer Highlights das schöne Gemälde
von Franz Franken dem jüngeren die
Bergpredigt ich beginne mit 40.000
€ für wie viel es jetzt versteigert
wurde dafür hören wir noch einmal in die
Auktion rein
45.000 € sind am Telefon geboten 45.000
€ gegen den Zahl 45.000 € sind geboten
45.000 € zum
ersten 45.000 € sind geboten zum zweiten
und
45000 niemand mehr zum ersten zweiten
und dritten für die
4001 ein letztes Mal Walter Straten der
Preis war auch geschätzt 40 bis 50 000
es gab bei der Auktion nur zwei Bieter
ein hatte ein Gebot ein schriftliches
Gebot 40.000 abgegeben und ein weiterer
Bieter hat den quasi spontan im Saal bzw
am Telefon mitgeboten bekam denn für 45
000 € den Zuschlag für ein Franz Franken
ist es ein guter Preis aber ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt ich habe die Auktion noch
im Fernsehen bzw im Livestream gesehen
ich hatte ehrlich erwartet dass mit
dieser ja doch sehr interessanten
Vorgeschichte möglicherweise ein höherer
Preis erzielt wird weil ich auch die
kleine Befürchtung hatte dass Leute da
möglicherweise mitbieten würden die
weniger an der Kunst als an der
nazeschichte interessiert werden das hat
sich zum Glück nicht herausgestellt so
gesehen ist 45.000 ein angemessener
Preis für ein Bild von Franz Franken und
hier endet unsere heutige Folge von
Tatort Deutschland wir hoffen sie hat
Euch gefallen zur Recherche nutzten wir
Artikel der fazz der S und des
Handelsplatz und natürlich das Wissen
von Walter Straten danke dafür noch mal
Walter und wir danken euch fürs zuhören
und freuen uns wenn ihr uns schreibt z.B
bei Instagram oder uns auf einer eurer
lieblingspodcast Plattformen eine gute
Bewertung hinterlasst wir freuen uns von
euch zu hören und zu lesen bis zum
nächsten Mal und bis dahin alles Gute
euer Mirko und euer
Stefan dir hat diese Folge von tartort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland